good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-939 object class
Keter special containment procedures
scp-939 - 1-3 1953 89 96 98 99 and 109
are kept in cell 1163 a or 1163 B 10 by
10 by 3 meter containment chambers with
an armed bio containment area 14 both
cells are environmentally regulated and
negatively pressurized with walls
constructed of reinforced concrete
access to these cells is regulated by an
outer decontamination chamber and inner
gas tight steel security doors
observation windows are constructed of
laminated ballistics glass 10
centimeters in thickness protected by a
100 kilovolt
electrified mesh humidity is maintained
at 100% at a temperature of 16 degrees
Celsius specimens are monitored at all
times via infrared cameras level 4
authorization is required to access
scp-939 their containment areas or the
observation chambers scp-939 - 101 is
dismembered and stored in cryogenic
preservation tanks 939 - 101 a - 939 -
101 m within biome research area 12
access - scp-939 - 101 requires
authorization by - clearance level 3
personnel one of which must be present
for all research and testing the
contents of only one 939 - 101 tank may
be accessed at any given time core
temperature of scp-939 - 101 tissues
must be monitored while removed from
geneq preservation should core
temperature exceed ten degrees Celsius
tissues are to be returned to their
corresponding tank and all testing
suspended for a period of 72 hours
barring core temperature exceeding 10
degrees Celsius research of scp-939 -
101 tissues may continue as long as its
ramblings and pleas for release may be
tolerated containment cells should be
cleaned by weekly while this takes place
scp-939 specimens will be transferred to
the adjacent cell during this time the
cells door and observation window must
be inspected for damage and repaired or
replaced accordingly heavy sedation of
all scp-939 is required before any
interaction including transfer between
cells and experimentation may take place
see document 939 te 4 or transfer and
experimentation protocol levels see has
met gears to be worn by personnel during
interactions with scp-939 specimens and
in any areas which scp-939 have been
known to inhabit afterward standard
decontamination procedures are to be
observed by all personnel involved to
ensure no secondary spread of amnestic
agents occurs following incident ABC a
14-9 39 - 3 all non d-class personnel
interacting with scp-939 for any length
of time are required to wear 2
waterproof electronic pulse monitors for
the duration of such interaction these
pulse monitors will transmit to a
wireless monitoring system independent
of a facility's main power grid with at
least one backup power system on standby
shoot both individuals pulse monitors
flatline or otherwise malfunction the
wearer will be presumed dead personally
instructed to disregard all the wearer's
subsequent vocalizations and a breach of
containment declared automatically
security personnel responding to such a
breach are likewise required to wear
these pulse monitors additionally I'll
live scp-939 must be implanted with
subdermal tracking devices upon capture
description scp-939 are endothermic pact
based predators which display atrophy of
various systems similar to try globe it
ik organisms the skins of scp-939 are
highly permeable to moisture and
translucent red owing to a compound
chemically similar to hemoglobin scp-939
average 2.2 meters tall standing upright
and weigh an average of 250 kilograms
though weight is highly variable each of
their four limbs and with three fingered
claws with a fourth opposable digit and
are covered in C tie which considerably
augment climbing ability their heads are
elongated devoid of even vestigial eyes
or eye sockets and contain no brain
casing the jaws of scp-939 are lined
with red faintly luminescent fang-like
teeth similar to those belonging to
specimens of the genus cheilitis up to 6
centimeters in length and encircled by
heat sensitive pit organs eye spots
sensitive to light and dark run the
length of their spines dorsal ridges
these spines may be up to 16 centimetres
long and are believed to be sensitive to
changes in air pressure and flow scp-939
do not possess many vital organ systems
central and peripheral nervous systems
circulatory system and digestive tract
are all absent scp-939 s respiratory
system is atrophied and serves no
apparent purpose beyond spreading a.m. n
C 22 7 scp-939 have no apparent
physiological need to feed nor any way
to digest consumed tissue ingest a
material typically accumulates in the
respiratory system of scp-939
and is regurgitated once the amount is
sufficient to markedly inhibit its
function despite the absence of many
vital organ systems scp-939 are capable
of bearing live young see addendum 10 16
1991 a CP 939 s primary method of luring
prey is the imitation of human speech in
the voices of prior victims though
imitation of other species and active
nocturnal hunts have been documented
scp-939 vocalizations often imply
significant distress whether scp-939
understand their vocalizations or are
repeating previously heard phrases is
the subject of ongoing study how scp-939
acquire voices is not currently
understood specimens have been
documented
imitating victims despite never hearing
the victims speak analysis of scp-939
vocalizations cannot distinguish between
scp-939 and samples of known victims
voices the use of biometric voice
recognition security or identification
systems at any installation housing
scp-939 is strongly discouraged for this
reason prey is usually killed with a
single bite to the cranium or neck bite
forces have been measured in excess of
35 mega pascals scp-939 exhale my new
traces of an aerosolized Class C
amnestic designated a MN C 20 to 7:00
a.m. NC 20 to 7 causes temporary and
terror grade amnesia inhibiting memory
formation for the duration of exposure
plus an average of 30 minutes it is
colorless odorless and tasteless with an
estimated ET c-54 inhalation of 0.001 5
milligrams per cute volume of the area
exposed in well-ventilated or open air
environments risk of exposure to ATC 50
is greatly reduced but not negligible AM
NC 20 to 7
typically undetectable in the
bloodstream 60 minutes following
cessation of exposure reported
sensations of disorientation and mild
hallucinations immediately following
removal from environments saturated with
the agent are similar to recreational
use of numerous psychoactive substances
and easily mistaken as such note March
23rd 2005 this report pertains to
morphology alpha for information
regarding morphology beta see experiment
log 914 a MTF news 7 after-action report
[Music]
addendum April 11th 1982 due to scp-939
s intense aversion to bright light it
has been deemed a minimal risk of escape
standard fluorescent hallway lighting is
sufficient to deter scp-939 - one from
leaving its darkened cell the following
addendum has been stricken from the
document and we are advised to see
addendum September 20th 1991 addendum
June 29 1987 preliminary research into a
MNC 22:7 suggests potential use as a
general purpose amnestic methods of mass
producing the agent as well as possible
adverse effects are being investigated
at biocontainment and research site 6
addendum October 3rd 1990 a.m. NC 22 7
has been approved for use as a Class C
amnestic projected annual production at
bio research area 12 by scp-939
respiratory tissue cultures is expected
to surpass 3 liters and again that
following addendum was stricken from the
official document
addendum September 20th 1991 containment
of nine scp-939 specimens has been
compromised following a silent night
breached scenario at bio containment and
research site six nearby civilian
settlements have been evacuated on the
pretense of a coming storm recovery
teams have been deployed to the area
addendum October 16 1991 in light of
this all interaction with a CP 939 from
September 8 to October 7th in the
Northern Hemisphere or March 6th to
April 4th in the southern hemisphere is
strictly forbidden
no male specimens of scp-939 have yet
been identified
contain a Class B amnestic
see reproduction of scp-939 document
number nine 3900 62 reproduction of
scp-939 on September 25th 1992 scp-939 -
one gave birth following a gestation
period of roughly 12 months litter
scp-939 a contains six specimens
numbered scp-939 a12 scp-939 a6 scp-939
a1 a 4 and a 5 were male while a 3 & a 6
were female scp-939 a2 was stillborn and
immediately cannibalized by scp-939 1
scp-939 1 made no attempts to interfere
with the confiscation of its offspring
vivisection of scp-939 - a1 a3 a4 and a5
found them to be morphologically and
genotypically indistinguishable from
healthy human infants the remains of
scp-939 a1 and 939 a3 are kept preserved
in biological material storage units 939
0 2 6 c and 939 - 0 to 6 d respectively
with in bio research area 12 remains of
scp-939 a4 and scp-939 a5 were
incinerated scp-939 a6 will be
transferred to for observation as it
matures it will undergo monthly physical
examination supplemented with any
additional measures deemed necessary
document number 939 - a six - sixteen
transfer of doctor note March 16th 1997
after overhearing numerous conversations
between personnel scp-939 a6 has come to
believe it's name is Keter given the
marked positive effect on its mood staff
are advised to neither encourage nor
discourage this assumption both its
mental and physical development have
remained consistent with human norms
document number 939 - a 6 - 33 emergency
medical log scp-939 a 6 date january 9th
2001 at approximately 2,000 hours
scp-939 a6 began acting increasingly
unsettled when questioned it reported a
sense of malaise breathing was observed
to be rapid and shallow scp-939 - a6 was
escorted to the medical ward for further
examination heart rate was measured to
be erratic averaging 100 90 beats per
minute no further anomalies were
observed scp-939 a6 was administered a
benzodiazepine and returned to contain
them probable panic attack trigger
undetermined
date january 10th 2001 at approximately
Oh for 30 hours scp-939 a six reported
the same symptoms accompanied by a mild
headache and aversion to light
examination returned identical results
to the previous day scp-939 a 6
instructed to rest administered a
sedative and returned to containment
date January 24th 2001 symptoms outlined
above persisted for two weeks before
intensifying scp-939 a 6 destroyed the
lighting fixture and its enclosure and
was found to have assumed the fetal
position underneath its bed at a 140
hours a 6 staunchly resisted leaving its
chamber requiring it to be carried to
area medical ward a complained of a
severe headache and intense aversion to
light hypersensitivity to auditory
stimuli intense chest and abdominal pain
and uncomfortable warmth commenting that
it hurts too much to cry a 6 is core
body temperature measured to be 41 point
2 degrees Celsius technicians were
unable to locate a pulse MRI indicated a
reinforced concrete containment cell was
immediately prepared for scp-939 a 6 the
cells lighting was dimmed in a large
Basin full of water provided and its
request date January 26 2001 scp-939 a6
immersed itself in the provided water
basin and remained inactive for a period
of approximately 41 hours at which point
it began violently tearing at its skin
it displayed a considerable amount of
distress upon realizing its skin was
sloughing off but appeared on able to
stop at 20 to 36 hours doctor
reported scp-939 a-sixes head detached
itself by twenty to forty hours
it appeared morphologically identical to
albeit much smaller and scp-939 - one
addendum february 13 2001 scp-939 a6 has
been redesignated to scp-939 101 it will
be transferred to bio research area 12
or further study
[Music]
document number 939 - 101 - 77 audio law
939 101 a number 13 begin log 10 16
hours May 22nd 2004 access to cryogenic
preservation room 939 101 granted to dr.
pol access to see GPT 939 101 a granted
playing log now have seen our pictures
he's like John daddy hung them on the
wall except for sometimes when the
others in white cost them away daddy
told us not to draw pictures of those
they made him sad so we did our best to
do all their things but sometimes we
forgot
sometimes daddy hated the pictures or
rip them off he told us that it wasn't
that he didn't like them he said it was
to keep us safe from the mean doctors in
the white coats but then the doctors
took Amy away they mean I was getting
shots in' told us to forget about daddy
but we were scared of needles without
batting around we didn't forget daddy
daddy forgot us so what you thinking was
the doctors fault daddy wouldn't forget
about us woody
it gave us a fake daddy told us it was
real daddy but we knew better
the doctors made us to get more shots
they kept telling us fake daddy was real
daddy but they couldn't fool us we told
them it was wrong to lie just like that
he told us and then they stopped lying
they made us be ourselves but it gave us
paper and pencils and paints and told us
we could draw whatever we wanted so we
did sometimes we'd read daddy sometimes
we do what daddy told us not to draw and
the doctors took all our pictures
sometimes the doctors and white coats
and the people with the black shirts
with a lot of pockets and helmets they
carry them windows and what did daddy
call them I forgot they walk with us
down the hall for our checkups he didn't
like those sometimes we had to lay in a
dark place to be really really still
daddy would tell stories he didn't
always understand them but we liked them
anyway there were stories about places
that didn't have ceilings where up was
forever and the ground wasn't white
could they get silly
everywhere our ceilings doesn't it after
the doctors took daddy away they didn't
get to hear stories anymore and we
didn't feel good
the doctors made us get loads of
checkups and we think they got scared so
we got scared too we had a really bad
headache and knowledge bothered us and
so did noises we wanted to find lots of
cool water away from the Brent lights
until our headache went away they let us
be in the dark and gave us lots of water
but the water made us itch all over when
we scratched sometimes our skin came off
we were so scared he kept asking for
daddy but he never showed up eventually
we didn't have any skin left but it was
okay because we didn't need it anymore
we stopped ditching after that the
lights stopped bothering us so much and
the headache went away after our old
head came off like still bother us but
not as much as they did we don't see
right anymore yes so hungry it was bad
who
in our old skin and our own head it
tasted good it was still bad we're still
hungry after that and asked for food
it gave us food even our favorite but
none of it tasted right to us all that
tasted good was one piece of meat we
asked for more of that they lock two
people in the dark with us
we asked him not to but then listen to
us we weren't hungry for a while after
that we're hungry now
we're very sorry we know lying is wrong
he didn't mean it
addendum February 20th 1992 effective
immediately
use of a MNC 22:7 as an amnestic is
suspended indefinitely consult incident
report a MNC 22:7 939 for further
information
this is incident am n c 22 7 939 SCP
involved scp-939 description On January
30th 1992 a statistical rate of missing
persons reports more than times the
national average was noted amongst
civilians administered a MN c 22 7
following the capture of SCP on november
28 1992 kilometers northwest of
pending further investigation use of amn
see 22:7 was suspended on january 31st
1992 field agent and were dispatched to
the area to investigate through
collaboration with local law enforcement
agent was able to secure an interview
with James approximately seven months
prior to the arrival of field agents
James reported three individuals missing
under suspicious circumstances all had
been previously administered a MNC 22:7
forward this interview is being
conducted by myself in order to confirm
or refute the possibility of a link
between the disappearances 1991 prior
administration of a MNC twenty two seven
two or four named individuals on the
28th of November 1990 thank you for
taking the time to meet with me mr. to
begin I'd like you to relate the events
of June 5th in as much detail as you
yeah okay
Brent we just have to go right this or
[ __ ] about the woods you know it was a
nice day out nothing seems strange until
I commented on a feeling of deja vu give
me a funny looking she said she felt it
too we all must have been the only smart
one
you got creeped out might all the rest
of us were curious and decided to look
into it I mean when have you ever heard
of five people all feeling deja vu at
the same time
can't say I ever have
please continue gotta be a stranger the
feeling of familiarity got stronger and
stronger in here yeah huge cake I don't
think any of us had ever been inside
before we only had one flashlight and it
was dumb as hell in hindsight but we
went inside the feeling kept getting
stronger
further anyway I know I keep calling it
deja vu but that's that's not the right
way to put it it was more of a general
feeling of familiarity not like this had
happened before but something about it
was just familiar and nobody could put
their finger on what the deeper we went
the more familiar it felt the more
certain we felt we were getting close to
what I don't know none of us knew and
that's why we get it going did you find
anything no well I don't know I remember
to be saying something about it getting
late we should turn back I don't
remember anything after that that until
if you need to what about your friends
closing statement my team is
ill-prepared to investigate further
we will be returning in the morning to
report our findings a minimal cover-up
should be necessary depending on what
foul at least for this particular
instance to this end I suggest Mr
Justice should be strongly implicated in
his friends disappearances following his
conviction he could be recruited from
the prison system as clearance level 0
janitorial staff and transferred to
whatever installation user agent
reported the possibility of n scp-939
den in the area and eradication detail
was dispatched to investigate scp-939
presence was confirmed within
and destroyed by February 6 1992 On
February 20th 1992 doctor confirmed the
sensation of familiarity reported by
James was solely attributable to a
hitherto undocumented effect of a second
exposure to aerosolized a.m. NC 22 7
following a first exposure of an
individual to ECT this sensation appears
to act as a lure in those affected by a
MNC 22:7 drawing them toward higher
concentrations most often centering
around dens of a CP 939 addendum March
1st 1992 a.m. NC 22 7 aided tracking of
a CP 939 we can use this anyone exposed
to a concentration high enough for
temporary and pterygoid amnesia to
manifest can stock them like bloodhounds
if they know how to identify the
misplaced sense of familiarity for what
it is based on agent retracing of the
route mr. J s and his friends followed
we know to expect an effective range of
kilometers if we use this form of
tracking no it can't find individual
scp-939 but it can guide us to their
dens I recommend we brief a number of
field operatives on this plant any
willing would then be exposed to a MNC
22:7 under controlled conditions and
dispatched first to the locations of
a.m. NC 20 to 7 use on civilian
populations any errant sensation of
familiarity experienced by these
operatives will be taken as
identification of n scp-939 den nearby
and reported as such eradication teams
will be dispatched to investigate
destroying these dens as they are
located after this has been accomplished
I believe the dispatch of these
operatives to major population centers
to facilitate their securing coupled
with standard monitoring civilian
military law enforcement
channels of information is the best
course of action to locate and
exterminate scp-939 in the wild
dr. okay I think that about does it for
today thank you very much for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Mookie slump God dr. day John Porter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator Nick tie verbal OD
tench cheese WEP
I'm Depp's McGee thank you all so much
for your support I really appreciate it
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on some
other cool stuff as well as at
patreon.com forward slash the vulcan
thank you
[Music]
you